[Musique]
alors
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce débat
d'entre deux tours sur tv 78 et radio
sensations
ce soir nous nous intéressons à la
commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
situation inédite le deuxième tour des
élections municipales a lieu trois mois
après le premier
ce sera le 28 juin prochain dans ce
contexte particulier ce débat ne se
tient pas en présentiel chaque candidat
est connecté avec nous trois listes sont
officiellement déclarés dans cette
commune comme nous l'indiquent la
préfecture alexandra rosetti 2020 listre
divers centres de la maire sortante unis
pour voisin liste divers droite menée
par olivier afonso et avec vous voisin
avant ce liste divers gauche mené par
béatrice pierrât bonsoir et merci à tous
les trois d'être présent alors je
rappelle que pour ces débats les temps
de parole sont chronométrées et
s'afficheront régulièrement au cours de
l'émission étant donné les conditions je
vous demanderais de ne pas vous couper
la parole les uns les autres je me
chargerai de vous la distribuer pour que
vous puissiez vous répondre pour débuter
nous ne pouvions pas faire abstraction
de l'épisode sanitaires que nous venons
de vivre en france durant cette période
nous avons pu observer l'émergence
parfois de nouveaux enjeux pour aborder
cela je vais commencer par vous
alexandra rosetti dans l'ordre dans
l'inscription de la préfecture nous
prendrons ce même ordre pour la
conclusion
alexandra rosetti vous êtes candidate
pour un deuxième mandat votre liste est
soutenue par l erp web ludique et le
modem
vous étiez déjà élu dans la commune
depuis 2001 et avait été élu maire en
2014 est réélu suite à un recours
également vice présidente de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de l'aménagement du
territoire et conseillère départementale
enfin vous êtes encartés udi et mener
une liste une liste divers centres
comment appréhendez-vous un nouvel
éventuelle à nouveau un éventuel nouveau
mandat je vais d'arrivée de mer dans ce
contexte actuel si particulière bonjour
d'écouté je vous remercie de cette
longue présentation juste pour être tout
à fait précis je suis également soutenue
par
le pays qui est une malveillance et
l'ère des départements et puis surtout
par génération terrain qui est un
mouvement qui a été créée par le maire
de poissy qui regroupe les maires pour
justement parler des actions de terrain
et ben justement c'est bien de ce qui
s'est passé avec cette crise je crois
que les communes ont eu un rôle majeur
un rôle d'amortisseur social et bien sûr
vos seins n'a pas fait exception à cette
règle et c'est bien sur le terrain
justement aux côtés des bénévoles que se
sont organisés les solidarités pour
accompagner les plus vulnérables il a
fallu apporter des solutions aux plus
précaires aussi tout en continuant bien
sûr informés dans la mesure du possible
la populace je crois qu'il faut alors au
delà bien sûr de de toute la peine qu'on
peut avoir pour les personnes qui ont
été en difficulté il faut se réjouir
quand même de ses élans de solidarité
qui ont vraiment démontré qu'on peut
faire beaucoup de choses tous ensemble
c'est des événements spontanés qui nous
on offre maintenant nous nous inciter à
en force et plus que jamais j'ai envie
de dire la cohésion entre les habitants
de nos voisins et donc c'est toujours
sur le terrain aller coûte en
particulier par exemple de nouveaux
commerçants plus on est des réponses
concrètes pour soutenir ces derniers
dans un contexte plutôt inédit donc on a
on a mis des masques jetables à
disposition alors c'était un contexte
était très tendue on a vient d'acter la
suppression par exemple des droites
terrasse pour les restaurants et puis on
a aussi beaucoup communiqué sur leurs
forêts les horaires d'ouverture tout ce
que faisaient nos nos commerçants donc
juste pour conclure ça a vraiment mis en
exergue un très bel aspect d'ailleurs du
rôle de mère qui est de prendre soin des
eaux d'être attentifs à leur bien être à
leurs besoins afin à leur santé donc
être simplement bienveillant olivier à
fond sur ce portail est une liste
d'union des élus d'opposition de la
droite actuelle unis pour voisins est
une liste divers droite soutenu par
libre le mouvement de la présidente de
région valérie pécresse et sur laquelle
on retrouve tirer gastaud vous êtes tous
deux élus d'opposition depuis 2015 même
question comment voyez vous cette
éventuelle mandat de
dans cette période particulière alors je
préciserai d'abord bonjour et merci
d'avoir organisé ce débat un peu
particulier je vous rends compléter le
rapport aux listes de soutiens que je
suis soutenu aussi par le parti du
nouveau centre et écologie bleus enfin
je suis affilié à aucun parti politique
et je garde toute mon indépendance à la
fois d'action et de parole
mes premières pensées d'abord bon pour
les huit mois qui ont été impactés par
ce virus
on a eu malheureusement à déplorer des
morts à voisins je voudrais remercier le
personnel enseignant au delà je voudrais
pas qu'une actualité comme ça en chasse
une autre
ils ont fait un travail extraordinaire
et j'ai été touchée puisque y compris
dans ma vie personnelle j'ai eu les gens
à impacter et ils font un boulot
extraordinaire et j'espère que y aura
bien une revalorisation de leurs
salaires parce que il mérite vraiment
qu'on contribue à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils nous ont donnée je voudrais aussi
remercier la région le département les
mérites voisins les élus toutes
tendances confondues les commerçants les
associations les vicinaux à eux mêmes et
ont fait preuve d'une grande générosité
d'une grande solidarité et c'est je
pense qu'il faut le souligner et et le
saluer ce confinement aussi nous a
permis de découvrir une ville qu'on
avait peut-être où on allait oublier
certains un certain charme comme le
calme le fait de ne pas avoir de
véhicules le fait qu'elle soit à moins
polluer plus agréable à vivre et elle a
mis aussi
enfin le confinement nous à l'année en
exergue aussi des situations des
situations de fragilité à la fois sur
des seniors mais aussi les plus jeunes
aussi puisque c'est pas pour rien qu'on
a fait une collecte alimentaire on s'est
retrouvé avec des jeunes qui ne
pouvaient pas forcément le sourire et ça
c'est un véritable problème et conflit
de conscience donc il ya eu une
véritable ce dernier est d'arrêter qui
s'est mis en place
je souhaite moi que cette solidarité
cette bienveillance continue sa vie a
aucun problème
mais les problèmes d'hier sont toujours
ceux d'aujourd'hui ils seront toujours
ceux de demain
si on ne fait rien et donc du coup mon
objectif de demers est justement prendre
à bras le corps les problèmes qui nous
pèse depuis un certain nombre d'années
et de les prendre à bras le corps pour
pouvoir enfin les réseaux alors béatrice
pierrât il s'agit de votre première
campagne politique pour votre liste
divers gauche avec vos voisins avance
vous vous êtes entouré d'élus municipaux
de l'opposition de gauche vous êtes
salarié dans l'industrie est engagée
dans l'associatif au sein d'une amap
comment envisagez-vous cet éventuel
mandat dans ce contexte l'or tout
d'abord merci pour l'organisation de ce
débat je souhaite d'abord au nom de
toute l'équipe adresser une pensée
amicale à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont été ou qui sont encore aujourd'hui
touchées par cette crise
je tiens également à remercier tous mes
trousses mais qu'ils se portaient
volontaires pourraient des populations''
pendant cette période j'ai d'ailleurs
moi-même été vraiment plaire pendant
cette période et je remercie également à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui nous ont
permis de vivre une vie la plus normale
possible pendant le confinement parce
qu'effectivement nous avons vécu une fit
sans précédent et cette crise dont le
père le mot solidarité elle a aussi mis
en évidence des inégalités et des
disparités que ce soit entre les jeunes
et les moins jeunes entre les
travailleurs et les sans emploi nous
amplifierons toutes les mesures visant à
plus de solidarité et plus de relations
intergénérationnelles
nous créerons par exemple une maison du
savoir partagé et nous mettrons tout en
oeuvre pour soutenir les acteurs locaux
qui font la vie la richesse et
l'attractivité de notre nid je pense
notamment à nos associations et âme aux
commerçants car la pandémie à fragiliser
certains commerçants et nous devons les
aider à passer ce cap difficile
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec certes un bon
chrono qui montrait par deux
tu es moins règne ensuite la crise
allait à monter aussi l'importance de
l'écologie c'est pour ça que c'est un
pilier très important dans notre
programme et d'en accélérer la
transition écologique et énergétique
parce que cette crise il ya eu un avant
il y aura un après aujourd'hui on voit
que beaucoup de personnes dans un
sentiment de rejet vis-à-vis des
transports publics et nous souhaitons
développer de façon beaucoup plus fort
mobilité douce et mettre en oeuvre des
plans ambitieux donc me plier les
piliers nous avions déjà pour le premier
tour de transition écologique de
démocratie participative et de
solidarité reste donc pertinent tenir
compte de la crise où nous avons aussi
ajouté de nouvelles mesures pour
préparer le monde après alors dans une
nouvelle fois au budget je vous préviens
juste vous êtes un peu long on démasque
on est passé il faudra garder du temps
pour la suisse alors je viens du temps
pour l'instant d'accord alors avant de
poursuivre et d'aborder notre première
thématique je vous propose ce reportage
il présente les principaux enjeux à
voisins le bretonneux pour ces élections
municipales trois candidats s'affrontent
pour ce second tour à voisins le
bretonneux
la maire sortante alexandra rosetti est
arrivé en tête avec 47 72 % talonné par
la liste d'union de l'opposition
actuelle menée par olivier afonso avec
34 86 %
enfin la liste divers gauche mené par
béatrice pira s'est maintenu également
avec 17 circuits 42% la commune et ses
onze 1426 habitants connaît un problème
de logement 6 590 logements ont
dernièrement été construit la ville a
tout de même perdu 1000 habitants 15 ans
en cause notamment le prix de
l'immobilier voisins le bretonneux doit
chercher à attirer de jeunes familles
un projet d'éco quartier est en cours
avec 500 logements et un jardin partagé
prévue pour 2022
à noter également le nombre de logements
sociaux la commune en comporte 18 5%
elle est en dessous des 25 % demandés
par l'état décide 2025
autre problématique d'urbanisme la
construction d'un troisième cimetière
le premier remplacement sélectionné au
square des 40 arpents a été contestés
par un collectif constitué spécialement
pour s'opposer à sa crise
a sion deux autres terrains sont à
l'étude la situation géographique de la
ville en porte de la vallée de chevreuse
lui causent des problèmes de circulation
elle est engorgé aux heures de pointe
chaque candidat propose des solutions
d'aménagement différentes pour régler ce
problème
une circulation dense qu'une association
de défense de la vie la peur de voir
amplifié par l'arrivée de la ligne 18 et
son nouveau quartier saint quentin est
enfin voisins le bretonneux n'est pas
épargné par la désertification médicale
les médecins présents actuellement sont
complets et approchent de la retraite un
projet de maisons fleuries
professionnels de santé est en cours des
généralistes et spécialistes sont
recherchés un enjeu dont l'importance
est accentuée avec la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus les thématiques de la
circulation et de l'urbanisme ayant été
largement abordés durant le débat du
premier tour je vous propose qu'on
apporte que l'on aborde d'autres sujets
les électeurs peuvent retrouver ce
premier débat en replay sur notre site
internet rubrique municipal 2020 avec
cet épisode inédit que nous venons de
vivre le thème de la santé de la
protection et l'autonomie des seniors
ressort naturellement voisins le
bretonneux compte actuellement dix
médecins généralistes dont la moitié
s'apprête à partir à la retraite
la population de près de onze mille
quatre cents habitants est relativement
jeune en comparaison avec la moyenne
nationale
mais à l'image de la population
française le nombre de seniors augmente
on fait un point sur les temps de parole
alexandra rosetti va être légèrement en
retard en étant moins de deux minutes on
a commencé avec vous il faut porter un
projet de maisons fleuries
professionnels de santé à la grande île
vous souhaitez également la création
d'une conciergerie avec services adaptés
pour les seniors de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit alors c'est pour les seniors
n'est pas que mais une conciergerie
c'est dans un ensemble des services
complets proposé de rendre aux gens qui
peuvent par exemple avoir besoin qu'on
leur fasse des des courses et qu'on leur
dépose quelque part ça peut être des
choses de la vie courante genre aller au
pressing enfin ça c'est un c'est un
enfant de services jeu direct qui peut
être intéressant à rendre mais pas
d'ailleurs que pour les pas d'ailleurs
que pour les seniors moi je sais que
j'ai remarqué c'est un peu la crise
aussi qui fait ressortir ressurgir
quelques sujets quelques thématiques
important celles de l'inclusion
numérique
on s'est rendus
donc pour communiquer pendant cette
crise était très complexe puisque il a
fini par dix journées mais mais moi j'ai
beaucoup pensé aux gens qui n'avaient
pas accès à internet et qui ne pouvait
donc pas avoir des informations comme
voilà le fasse aussi facilement que les
autres personnes donc je crois que les
personnes âgées c'est pas c'est sont pas
nés avec sont pas forcément nés avec le
digital
donc il y a à mon avis à un gros travail
à mener sur l'inclusion numérique voilà
après il ya aussi ce qu'on a mis dans le
programme c'est-à-dire adapter la ville
au grand âge je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important
alors c'est tout simple c'est poser des
bancs sur des parcours des promenades
ses avoirs gpo à l'aide publique qu'ils
soient intégrées et adaptées
il ya également tout ce qui concerne
bien sûr le handicap avec là il faut
poursuivre la mise aux normes des
trottoirs les signalétiques mettre en
place des signalétique adaptée pour
suivre la conformité des bâtiments
publics même si maintenant je pense
qu'elle est pratiquement terminé et puis
également trouver des solutions de
mobilité on avait engagé un travail avec
au ccas sur le les seniors et leur
isolement et il était ressorti de façon
assez forte besoin de se déplacer plus
facilement à l'intérieur de la ville
donc effectivement il faudrait pouvoir
tester une solution de navettes
électriques ou pas ça je ne sais pas
encore mais au moins pour relier les
centres commerciaux les des centres
médicaux ça c'est quelque chose qui
était apparu de façon assez nette
et puis je crois également que nos
seniors ont besoin de toujours plus de
moments de convivialité de rencontre
également par rapport à leur santé on a
mis en place vaut mon oncle pour suivre
des ateliers de motricité pour qu'ils
puissent parfois regagner une autonomie
selon leur âge et puis également on
souhaite nommer un référent seniors par
quartier pour qu'ils puissent nous faire
remonter justement du terrain les
retours d'expérience concernant les
aménagements qui serait à réaliser ou à
modifier
voilà ça c'est ce qui compte
seniors après sur la santé je pense que
y'avait un élément fort dans nos
programmes concernés les aidants parce
que les aidants vivent des choses
extrêmement déçu si vous arrivez à 5
minutes on a quand même deux important
qu'avoir des verts c'était pour dire que
la santé va au delà de la création d'une
maison pour les professionnels il faut
faire attention aussi à toute cette
population qui a besoin d'elle dans son
quotidien
alors d'être respirait à vous proposer
de valoriser l'intergénérationnel en
proposant mentalement d'ouvrir le
restaurant municipal et scolaire aux
seniors tout à fait la crise a montré
les difficultés liées notamment à
l'isolément des seniors nous pensons
qu'il faut que les seniors soient
impliqués dans la ville donc vous avez
pris l'exemple de l'ouverture il des
seniors le fouet de l'assurance va les
obliger à utiliser les structures de
restauration de la ville nous pensons
aussi à la mise en place d'une maison
des savoirs partagés pour créer un lien
intergénérationnel et permettre les
contacts entre les seniors et les plus
jeunes pour les seniors c'est une façon
de les ouvrir on a parlé du numérique
sur des technologies que les plus jeunes
les crises parfois beaucoup le même que
nous et aussi pour faire partager
l'expérience des plus anciens avec les
jeux maintenant sur le sujet de la santé
ou ailleurs dans l'agglo que la ville de
guyancourt a mis en place une maison
hantée demain c'est montigny le
bretonneux qui va suivre le même chemin
nous avons également faculté de médecine
dans l'agglomération il est important de
trouver des façons avec bien sûr
l'agencé régionale de la santé la race
des façons de faire venir des médecins
dans la ville voir dans l'agglo car
voisins-le-bretonneux n'est pas un
village gaulois en france dès cette
partie quand même d'une grande
agglomération pour permettre à toutes
les vies si nous avait tous les chinois
un médecin référent et de pouvoir suivre
leur santé de façon continue on a parlé
de la mobilité tout à l'heure où les
biens-fonds sauve ou de porter un projet
de navette communal pour les seniors
notamment
oui d'abord mais moi je
je suis ravie quand on arrivait à
trouver des convergences donc madame
rose éthique propose la navette
c'est bien non puisque je le proposais
aussi donc c'est quelque chose si c'est
elle qui gagne ou si c'est moi qui gagne
les élections
madame dira si elle le propose on le
mettra en ondes c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour le seigneur et je note que
madame pierrât s'est inspiré d'une idée
que l'on nous avions sorti il ya
plusieurs mois il ya six mois sur la
cantine pour les seniors là aussi je
trouve que c'est formidable si un de
nous deux gagne ces élections il pourra
le mettre en place et c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour nos seniors
oui en fait l'histoire du déplacement je
pense que c'est un axe extrêmement
important moi je me suis aperçu quand je
me suis promené à la remise pour
rencontrer les visiteurs je suis tombé
sur un monsieur qui a 85 ans 85 88 et
kim expédie dallas il a arrêté la moitié
l'ont clairement et il a aucun moyen de
transport pour aller au centre village
et c c'est suite à cet entretien que
j'ai eu avec cette personne là que j'ai
eu cette idée sur sur la navette
alors après les idées les amants elle
circule on la regarde un peu ce qui est
fait dans différentes villes et ça me
semble être une idée à une idée
intéressante qui va nous coûter un peu
séquelles au niveau de la halte et rixes
et pas c'est pas donné mais c'est une
obligation pour nous que de permettre à
nos seniors 2 se déplacent et nous
propose aussi d une résidence
en fait pour les personnes âgées
autonomes ou centre village je pense que
nous faisons une erreur de faire des
logements et des logements pour les
seniors à l'extérieur du centre village
parce que tout est concentré de ce
village
donc soit ne soit nous mettons en place
un véritable transport pour les
personnes âgées ou les personnes à
mobilité réduite
je pense le quart de la manivelle nous
allons qu'on soit 97 logements
il ya une
résidence pour personnes âgées alors
qu'à part un bus qui nous permet les
partir de ce point là et de venir au
centre village
donc soit vous mettez en place cette
navette soit nous sommes nous obligés de
centraliser ce genre d'établissement au
centre lui large pour que nos seniors ne
soit pas isolée
les participes peremans à la billotte à
notre vie municipale et puissent accéder
aux commerçants aux médecins à la mairie
tout simplement et là je rejoins un peu
ce que disait même rosetti ça nous
semble extrêmement important la fracture
numérique c'est à dire que nous il ya
toute une génération qui baigne dedans
et puis il ya les personnes âgées qui
sont pas forcément dedans ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas et les personnes
âgées qu'ils disent très bien internet
mais effectivement notre communication
jusqu'à un moment donné il va falloir
quand même pour reste sur une
communication du classique pour que
quand on a ce genre de cas avec la
chorale virus on puisse communiquer avec
tous les vices et noir donc en tout cas
il y aura toute une génération on sera
obligé de de faire comme ça dernière
chose on n'a pas parlé du tout
importante il appuie le social il faudra
peut-être d'y venir parce que après la
crise sanitaire il ya véritablement une
crise sociale qui s'annonce alors
alexandre est résulté vous n'avez pas
réagir en 10 secondes de ce que vous
êtes on a beau oui mais quand même ça
mérite une petite réaction juste
rappeler à madame pirates qui parle de
guyancourt et de montigny que donc aussi
un voisin il y aura une maison qui
s'appelle pluri professionnelle de santé
donc vous inquiétez pas on est parti
pour sa juste aussi sur l'ouverture de
la cantine aux seniors j'ai bien vu ça
dans vos programmes
j'avoue que je ne sais pas comment vous
allez faire nous avons déjà extrêmement
molle accueillir tous les enfants qu'il
y ait eu mangent à la cantine en voisins
a ajouté des seniors je ne saurais pas
où les mettre
mais bon voilà c'est que je mets ça
votre peu important c'est juste pour
vous dire que des fois quand on est son
terrain effectivement au débat d'idées
sont pas faciles à mettre en oeuvre
s'il vous plaît à venir s'il veut nous
attendait là on ne s'entend pas si vous
parlez en même temps je voulais à
l'armada me restait manager fini sur la
manivelle pour dire que c'est quand même
à lui même si c'est pas tourné vers
voisins il ya les médecins autour il ya
un vétérinaire et des bus pour se
déplacer autour de la mer
donc c'est il ya un bel endroit de
promenade dont ce n'est pas à proprement
parler tourner vers le centre voisin
mais il ya beaucoup de commerces et tout
laisse donc c'est quand même une
situation qui est quand même assez
favorable pour des personnes âgées
l'amènera vous pouvez les gradins d'un
mois d'été oui je souhaitais précisé qu'
en terme de restauration nous parlions
de la restauration municipale au niveau
des ateliers municipaux pas forcément
des restaurations scolaires et au niveau
de la maison de santé vous avez
effectivement pour minutes maison santé
lors des élections dans le quartier de
la grande île mais nous ne l'avons pas
encore abel est en cours ça se sait pas
on a trouvé un lieu on a bien de trouver
un médecin
on va changer fenêtre thématiques ou là
je vais vous faire un point sur le temps
madame rose et si vous êtes ça six
minutes une ampera quatre minutes cinq
minutes pour monsieur alfonso donc je
prends la thématique s'il vous plaît
parce que je voudrais pas non plus comme
ça on balance des choses comme ça moi ce
qui est important c'est que nous aimions
puissent accéder au centre administratif
il est important que les seniors
puissent aller en irak la deuxième c'est
tellement s'est lancée un peu long je ne
suis pas raciste mais après je me tais
et aucun problème et ensuite
enfin je sais ça promet cela va être
difficile de l'avenir mais mais et la
deuxième chose sur la manivelle
moi j'aimerais bien que les seniors
puissent consommer d'enterrer sainte et
restaurants vie si noah et puissent
dépenser leur argent chez les
commerçants les sinois et c'est mieux de
les avoir au centre que de les avoir un
monte in me semble-t-il
là on va pouvoir aborder le thème de la
démocratie et le rôle des élus alors par
contre je vais vous freinez on arrive à
la moitié de l'émission déjà de la terre
la thématique de l'environnement pourra
pas l'aborder que la manuelle se situe à
côté de chez moi
pour rappel les vielles à fond la carte
des villes de voisins oui le lady voisin
n'est pas
gaulle en france mais c'est une ville de
l'agglomération et je pense que vous
entend pas si vous parlez en même temps
je vais reprendre la main et je vais
avancer dans ce débat qu'on apporte la
thématique de la démocratie je vais
arriver comment souhaitez-vous faire
vivre la démocratie au sein de
voisins-le-bretonneux je rappelle qu'ils
en pensaient lune et c'est pas bien sûr
et la ville a aussi trois conseils de
quartier accès qu'un conseil municipal
des jeunes je rappelle également que
voisins le bretonneux fait partie de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines yvelines et que quatre élus
peuvent siéger au conseil
d'agglomération d'être espira j'ai
commencé avec vous êtes à 4 minutes 30
vous installez vous insister sur la
démocratie participative et entendait
notamment créer une assemblée vicinaux
rays de quoi s'agit-il
tout à fait alors pour nous d'abord le
rôle des élus doit être un rôle
exemplaire car les nus et l'exécutif
local et nous avons eu le besoin
d'écrire madhav le vert pour lui
rappeler l'article numéro 1 de
l'ordonnancé du gouvernement publié le
1er avril 2020 visant à assurer la
continuité du fonctionnement des
institutions locales qui en contrepartie
d'un élargissement de pouvoir imposer
une obligation d'information
donc nous allons rappeler à madame le
maire le mois dernier ce pont
d'obligations de la formation car pour
nous une réunion entre madame le maire
et deux élus ne signifie pas une
information vers l'ensemble des élus du
conseil municipal et ne répondent pas à
l'ordonnancé telle que le gouvernement
l'a stipulé
donc pour nous la démocratie
participative c'est la communication
vers l'ensemble des élus car l'ensemble
des élus me représente la population je
rappelle qu'une ville comme
voisins-le-bretonneux et une ville
plurielle avec des quartiers qui sont
différents on a pas que le plan de
l'église et champ fleuri et que tous les
élus représentent leurs quartiers et les
différentes constituante
des habitants de la ville et dans
l'instant s'ils doivent être consultés
et informés pour nous
vision qui concerne la ville vous pouvez
tomber en place une assemblée v6 noir
c'est un voisin quant aux noeuds a
aujourd'hui besoin de prendre des
décisions stratégiques
je pense notamment à la ligne 18 qui va
bientôt arriver puisque les chante et
2030 et nous avons besoin de réfléchir
de faire comprendre où les coordonnées
avec nos communes partenaires de
l'agglomération pour permettre la
préparation au mieux de la gare qui va
impacter notre vie la réaction d'un
rosetti vous avez été mais vous avez été
mise en cause je voulais ce que pourrait
même cas mais d'abord je suis avec mon
âme pires a été élu puisqu'elle dit nous
avons c'est très bien peut-être que
monsieur je vous ai pas tout raconter je
sais pas moi j'ai j'ai vraiment passé du
temps je pense que monsieur à
fonctionnement en témoigner ou moi là
dessus j'espère non non c'est faux j'ai
vraiment connu des visio j'ai associé
l'opposition la distribution des masses
que j'avais envoyé un mail pour
expliquer des choses il ya eu un petit
loupé sur l'envoi de décision qui
d'ailleurs n'avait pas aux grands de
battre ça peut arriver des choses comme
ça quand on est en temps de crise et que
la mairie est vide
il peut arriver que il ya des petits
bouquets je m'en suis expliqué au
conseil municipal
je trouve que c'est un petit peu mesquin
de sortir cette histoire surtout dans le
courrier quand on m'explique qu'on nous
demande un conseil municipal j'avais
annoncé que jean frère mais je pense que
monsieur françois pour en témoigner
la démocratie locale bien sûr s'y
impliquer les élus mais c'est aussi
impliquer les habitants et par attendre
que les idées viennent d'eux il faut
aussi leur proposer des idées
et puis les faire débattre à partir de
ça je pense que ce qui est très
important aussi c'est qu'eric garder
l'intérêt général à l'esprit quand on
fait des concertations parce que
rapidement les gens si on sait quoi ça
les arrange pas que tout près de chez
eux ils auraient tendance à pas vouloir
arrêter des chansons qu'il faut arriver
à trouver un juste équilibre entre le
dialogue
et puis le moment de la décision voilà
je pense qu'on est élu pour prendre des
décisions après il peut arriver qu'on se
trompe il faut aussi accepter l'idée
qu'on peut il faut avoir la capacité de
se remettre en cause moi j'ai prouvé
dans ce mandat que j'avais cette
capacité
mais toujours garé dans l'intérêt
général à lescout olivier afonso quel
serait votre façon d'agir en tant que
maire vous savez moi je vais pas revenir
sur la gestion du coc u19 parce que
c'est un retour en arrière
moi je peux simplement témoigner qui a
eu deux réunions avec monsieur h moi
même
madame rossetti et des agents de la
ville je dois le reconnaître lundi au
conseil municipal ces réunions étaient
constructives l'état et la première
intervention que j'ai eu à faire au sein
du conseil municipal il ya cinq ans
c'était pour réclamer justement qu'il y
ait plus de coordination entre les élus
de l'opposition et la majorité
bon à part ça qu'est ce qu'on va faire
demain
moi je suis intimement convaincu qu'il
faut éviter le conflit oppose et l'ebit
sinois entre eux est présent sur le
terrain c'est une question de méthode
donc je veux plus de concertation plus
des coupes plus de proximité
à l'arrivée ça donne de la confiance et
l'efficacité pour être garant de ça je
veux nommer un élu de l'opposition
garant de la concertation publique c'est
clair je suis le seul aujourd'hui à dire
qu'il veut et que je donnerai des
responsabilités à l'opposition pour une
raison très simple je préfère une
opposition qui travaille plutôt qu'une
opposition
si vous voulez qu'ils et méprisées et
exclues pour moi un élu reste un élu
quel que soit en fait au fond sa
position autour de la table du conseil
municipal et je peut instaurer des
référendums locaux il ya des sujets
aujourd'hui oui il va falloir trancher
tout ne se réglera pas non plus en
demandant sans arrêt la vie des gens là
je rejoins m.rosetti à un moment donné
on voit des sites mais quand on décide
il faut décider sur une méthode juste le
cimetière en l'occurrence par ailleurs
peut-être qu'on y reviendra
c'est l'exemple typique de la méthode
raté c'est comment opposé lévy sinois
entre sur un sujet qui étaient 110 net -
nous rassembler à vous pouvez ne pas
être d'accord mais c'est la vérité je
veux désirs et des élus responsables
j'en ai assez qu'on m'explique que c'est
toujours la faute des autres c'est
jamais la faute de madame le maire
c'est pas moi c'est l'agglo mais alors
pourquoi cumulés pourquoi être vice
président de l'agglo pourquoi et au
département
quand on rejette la faute sur les autres
donc je veux des élus responsables et
des élus
effectivement aussi assidus aux
commissions et au conseil municipal
si vous abordez le sujet de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour des questions de toute
parole je voulais parler vous à ce sujet
béatrice pierrât vous souhaitez
améliorer le travail collectif avec
saint quentin en yvelines
oui pour nous comme je les dis déjà
plusieurs fois ce soir voisins le
bretonneux n'est pas un village
indépendants en france
c'est une des villes de l'agglomération
de saint quentin mais comme l'a rappelé
olivier affronte aujourd'hui même le
maire d'istres résidence de
l'agglomération et les décisions au delà
de la ville doivent être prises en
concertation avec les autres communes
car ensemble on est beaucoup plus fort
et je pense et nous pensons au sein de
la liste qu'il est important que nous
ayons des décisions qu'ils aillent dans
le pense de 50 à merveille et que son
départ était vous siégez actuellement
l'opération saint quentin en yvelines
donc eux-mêmes mais aussi en tant que en
charge de l'aménagement du territoire
également conseillère départementale
quels avantages vous retenez de cette
différence d'expérience alors déjà je ne
dis pas que c'est la faute de l'agglo je
dis toujours que la difficulté qu'on a
dans nos communes en tout cas dans les
sept premiers c'est que ya des terrains
qui appartiennent à la ville d'autres
qui appartiennent à l'agglo doute la
partie l adsl mais j'explique juste aux
gens que l'on n'a pas la main sur les
terrains qui appartiennent à la loue
donc on est obligé de passer par eux ça
veut pas dire qu'on va pas faire c'est
juste que on est sûrement souvent moins
réactif
parce que c'est pas notre propre terrain
c'est tout moi j'assume tout ce qui va
bien mais tout ce qui va mal j'ai aucun
souci avec ça l'avantagé c'est que
effectivement ça m'a fait travailler
avec toutes les communes et en
particulier la thématique de
l'aménagement m'a amené à échanger
énormément avec les autres maires je
fais partie de tous les groupes de
pilotage des projets d'aménagement ce
qu'il donne une vraie vision d'ensemble
et ça m'a énormément apporté pour voisin
parce que ça m'a permis je dirais de
mettre des outils en place de mieux
comprendre comment son excellent
ménagement les façon à maîtriser le
devenir de notre ville donc ça a été
vraiment un gros bénéfices pour voisins
et je m'entends extrêmement bien avec
tous les maires de la preuve c'est que
la restauration scolaire c'est une
entente avec la ville de trappes
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer lycée
morton pour parler justement de l'avenir
terrain thales je suis tout en
permanence dans le dialogue avec nicolas
voilà être respira qu'elle relevait vous
entendez jouer autant enceinte saint
quentin en yvelines
alors pour nous saint quentin en
yvelines et donc effectivement
l'agglomération et les 50 plus grands
également de nombreuses décisions qui
ont un impact pour la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux donc il est
important que les élus de la ville
puisque là je rappelle que nous parlons
des actions municipales mais également
d'élections communautaire donc il est
important que les élus de la ville
défendre les intérêts de la vie au sein
d'agglomérations
alors je fais un point sur les tentes
par alexandre arroser si vous êtes
pratiquement neuf minutes 7 minutes 30
pour béatrice pierre à une minute pour
les billets à fond saut je vais vous
laisser parler comme de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous assurez vous concentrer uniquement
sur la commune de voisins le bretonneux
et ne pas prendre de vice-présidence à
l'agglomération pourquoi bon il y aurait
donc qu'elle simple moi je suis contre
le cumul des mandats et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le rôle du vice
présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération c'est de faire vivre la
machine de saint quentin en yvelines
si ce rôle-là servait à défendre les
intérêts de boisin probablement qu'on
aurait résolu le problème de la
circulation
on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'on a perdu 6
ans sur le sujet d'ailleurs entre
guillemets madame rosetti a même
supprimé une une étude sur la
circulation tant promise en 2019 elle a
bien fait puisque j'étais contre un an
des élections la ficelle était énorme
moi je pense sincèrement qu'aujourd'hui
il faut un mairie père actif qui
défendent les intérêts des voisins avec
une liberté d'action de l'oms
je ne serai pas le collaborateur de
monsieur x ou son monsieur bédié je
serai un partenaire et j'ai l'intention
mois de disputes avec les autres maires
à égalité je ne dépendrait pas une d'une
dune d'une instance
j'ai un chef d'entreprise à côté de moi
qui travaille à 55
qui sera vice président de l'agglo qui
assurera cette fonction sans problème
et tous les deux nous défendrons au sein
de la communauté d'agglomération lui en
tant qu'ex-président et moi en tant que
maire de bosses dames les intérêts de
voisins mais une chose est sûre c'est
que ça va changer
je ne serai pas le collaborateur de ce
faubourg bédié je vais vous arrêter ici
merci alors béatrice cas si vous
souhaitez vous vous exprimez vous avez
encore du temps après on passera la
conclusion alors un point que nous
n'avons pas abordé lors des premiers
débats ce soir c'est l'écologie pour
nous l'écologie est vraiment dans nos
gènes et ce ne sont pas quelques mesures
comme la mise en place cette femme mère
ou des jardins partagés qui tourne en de
l'écologie pour nous l'écologie une
véritable politique qui doit être menée
par la vigne et il doit être une
ambition dans tous les choix qui sont
faites notamment la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et des
décisions qui vont vers la transition
écologique vers une énergie maîtrisée et
une économie bas carbone
là on apprend que j'allais être un il
vous reste chacun la conclusion j'ai
fait un point sur les temps de parole
neuf minutes pour alexandra rosetti
minutes pour battre espira 9 menu pour
olivier afonso vous avez environ tous
entre une minute trente et une minutes
pour vous exprimer sur cette conclusion
je rappelle ou prenez la thématique de
votre choix
on va commencer avec volée via la
fonction vous avez une minute et ben je
vais conclure simplement lévy sinois
connaissent mon projet mon équipe
ce sont des mesures concrètes il faut
arrêter avec le blabla habituel il faut
prendre à bras le corps les sujets qui
qui sont devant nous depuis une éternité
vous me connaissez je suis pas je suis
quelqu'un de profondément honnête
attachés à notre ville je dis aux
piscénois qu'il est temps de prendre
notre destin en main j'ai une équipe de
deux dynamiques j'ai eu six jeunes
autour de moi consiste à 25 ans moi je
ne crois pas pour contre le voisin
demain en tournant le dos à la jeunesse
on aura besoin d'elle je veux absolument
qu'elle fera qu elle prenne avec moi à
bras le corps les sujets parce que le
voisin demain c'est pour eux c'est avec
eux voilà pourquoi je me suis engagé le
sait pour la jeunesse de notre ville
alex mois arrêtiez pour conclure vous
avez une minute également moi je veux
juste dire que
la crise inédite que nous avons
traversée a vraiment mis en valeur les
atouts de voisins et en particulier par
exemple les magnifiques des espaces
verts maîtriser des nombreuses
promenades plébiscité par les dix mois
qui si j'avais écouté mes opposants on
avait l'impression qu'ils avaient pas du
tout des espaces verts à voisins ça a
mis en valeur nos petits commerces de
proximité de qualité et c'est vrai qu'il
va falloir vraiment être à leurs côtés
les aider sans dire aussi que la
couverture totale de la ville de par la
fibre a permis de s'assurer du
télétravail et puis je crois qu'il faut
pas hésiter effectivement maintenant
aller au daeu de nos compétences
régaliennes il faut savoir faire preuve
d'agilité et d'une très forte
implication pour assurer la continuité
du service public dont c'était de cette
période qui était inédite et
l'agglomérât je ne suis pas lié la
collaboratrice de leur boulot je suis
une élue qui déforme les intérêts de sa
commune
et puis je crois que c'est bien dans les
épreuves qu'on s'est révélé et cette
ville la vis de voisins a vraiment
répondu présent pour ses habitants et
donc avec mon équipe qui est dynamique
et qui est ancré dans tous les quartiers
et qui représente la sociologie de
voisins et bien nous avons aval afin de
poursuivre la maîtrise de notre
développement
ou alors mais tu respires à 7 à vous
pour conclure il vous reste une minute
merci de me donner la parole de notre
côté sur notre liste nous pensons que la
ville aurait besoin de sérénité
nous pensons que la ville a vécu pendant
des plusieurs années chez pas eu des
chiffres mais pendant plusieurs années
des querelles notamment des querelles
entre les candidats historique de la
droite vis chinoise et nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui avec la crise que nous
affrontons le plus important est d'être
unis tout son sens car je veux pas dire
tous unis au mois d'août unis au sein du
conseil municipal
effectivement pour défendre les villes
chinoises et les vies si noir au sein de
l'agglomération car nous vivons
aujourd'hui et nous pensons que nous
allons vivre une période qui est quand
même très difficile et nous devons au
delà
de nos querelles pour diverses raisons à
agir de concert pour un bien comme s'ils
voulaient ajouter quelque chose mais tu
respires restaient bas que pour moi
c'est ma première campagne électorale
donc je découvre ce monde je ne suis pas
en politique pour une question
personnelle alors j'ai déjà un emploi
dans l'industrie je n'ai pas besoin
d'être honnête pour subvenir à mes
besoins je fais ça ose tout et je le
souhaite défendre avec le plus de force
possible
les mines chinoises et les vies si noah
et que dans tous les cas je pense être
au conseil municipal pour les prochaines
années à venir et pour les 3 août grand
l'occasion de travailler ensemble et que
vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
défendre ceux qui ont choisi de voter
pour lui au premier tour que je remercie
et qui continueront à nous donner
confiance où vous êtes
merci alors les temps de parole sa fiche
pour la conclusion
alexandra rosicky vous êtes a diminué de
0 5 buts respire à 9 minutes 51 olivier
à françois neuf minutes 55 ce débat
s'achève ici vous remercie tous les
trois d'avoir joué le jeu dans ces
conditions particulières
je le rappelle le second tour aura lieu
le 28 juin vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission à ripley sur notre site
internet et en podcast sur tes sur radio
sensations
merci de nous avoir suivis et bonne
soirée
[Musique]
à